[Music]
zac efron and jessica alba show off
their dance moves on tick tock
[Music]
jess uploaded the cute video to her
account writing quote that time in dubai
i got zac efron to do a tick-tock dance
with me while shooting movie trailers
for dubai tourism yeah i take myself
really seriously that dubai tourism
trailer that just mentioned well it's a
commercial the pair filmed zach uploaded
the 30-second video to his instagram
you're just
always putting work first
look i don't want to fight with you
really
he might
we've been compromised
seriously this is your plan
thank you
oh wow
but back to that tick tock dance it
makes sense zach is literally known for
his moves yeah it is it's very fitting
yeah from his high school musical days
[Music]
to when things got a little more risque
in neighbors too
[Applause]
zach also proved he could pull dance
while on the graham norton show in 2017.
typical adult stuff dancing aside we
also know zach is big on adventures
in 2018 he told et all about his
thrill-seeking hobby skydiving is pretty
good uh no i i did like
i did some gnarly skydiving
before i was probably
adequately
uh
like trained i think i like i started
jumping out of helicopters at pretty low
altitudes as for jessica the dance video
is right up her alley she's big on tick
tock
[Music]
you know i really learned from my 11
year old how to do tick tocks not gonna
lie she gives me all the tips